et sans détour fadela amara réponse ce
soir à nos questions bonsoir bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous vous avez que
vous êtes présidente de l'association ni
[ __ ] ni soumises vous êtes membre de la
haute autorité de lutte contre les
discriminations et pour l'égalité puis
vous cosigné avec mohamed abdi la
racaille de la république un ouvrage
paru au seuil alors là il ya un an les
maires comme stéphane gatignon ont été
mais en première ligne est ce que vous
pensez qu'ils ont été entendus tpr et
franchement je pense que le cricket
annoncé le cri de colère qui a été lancé
l'année dernière a été presque entendue
mais il ne se traduit pas concrètement
par des mesures qui permettent de
changer la situation dans les quartiers
notamment se pense particulièrement à la
jeunesse l'a entendue dans le reportage
40 % de jeunes qui sont en situation de
chômage c'est catastrophique
et donc il ya vraiment besoin au-delà de
la question de dd les principes au delà
de l'annoncé que ça il faut vraiment
changer la situation aujourd'hui
au final tous les ingrédients sont là
encore malheureusement pour que ça ça
serait bolt encore une fois rappeler nos
lesquels 15 ans craignant l'exclusion
des discriminations la précarité qui
s'est installée et ce sentiment surtout
d'injustice qui est largement partagée
par l'ensemble des en-cas dicte ses
quartiers en difficulté alors stéphane
gatignon le maire de sevran qu'on a vu
dans ce reportage de manque plus de
policiers dominique de villepin
réaffirme aujourd'hui ce qui a déjà été
dit par lui et par nicolas sarkozy que
les patrouilles notamment seront
renforcés dans les quartiers votre peau
moi je suis très attaché à l'égalité
républicaine et le droit à la sécurité
je parte à la sécurité parce que ça
amène à des concepts de d'exclusion l'on
a tendance à stigmatiser une catégorie
de population
moi je parle du droit la sécurité pour
tous et ça suppose que les gens qui
habitent les quartiers en difficulté ont
droit comme tout le monde comme les gens
qui habitent dans les quartiers dont
vous accuser la police de proximité par
exemple beaucoup pour la police depuis
de proximité on l'a dit parce que ça
permet justement une sorte de dialogue
entre la jeunesse et la police on sait
bien les difficultés qui a en termes de
dialogue et de rapport avec la jeunesse
et et les flics pour aller très vite
je pense qu'il ya un vrai besoin il ya
aussi besoin de répondre à l'ensemble de
toutes les problématiques de ce qu'on
appelait dans les années 80 les manistes
des banlieues mais pour
pour revenir plus précisément sur ce
dialogue dont vous parlez entre la
jeunesse et les flics ce que vous dites
il est meilleur moins bon qu'il y a un
an à la même époque
je vais être honnête je pense que ça
s'est un peu plus dégradée en réalité
parce qu'il à faire par exemple drame de
ziad de bouna n'y a pas eu de réponse
électrocuté dans le dans le local edf
oui ça a été terrible et en fait ça je
dirais à mener à une radicalisation des
comportements des jeunes et puis surtout
un rosier vraiment de de la police
républicaine alors que moi je suis
convaincu qu'il faut absolument prendre
des initiatives qui permettent de
reconstruire ce dialogue là parce que
dans les quartiers on a besoin aussi
d'être protégé et de vivre en sécurité
comme tout le monde vous aurez que la
jeunesse un peu particulier il faut
absolument par exemple si une réponse
par exemple sur le drame qu'elle a vécu
ziad et la famille de zyed et bouna
c'est impératif
alors pour vous vous dites qu'il faut
faire quelque chose en profondeur pour
les quartiers 100 millions d'euros ont
été alloués aux associations
le programme de rénovation urbaine se
chiffre en milliards d'euros sur sur
plusieurs années sur sur mi-temps
précisé me dise s'étaler sur plusieurs
années
oui mais il ya quand même de l'argent
qui est des mots clés ce sont des
grosses sommes on peut pas dire que rien
n'est fait en terme financier forum un
nouvel écart tiers non il ya déjà eu un
début je dirais sous gouvernement
d'avant où on a commencé à parler de la
politique de la ville on a commencé à
parler d'une nouvelle urbanisation et
c'est monsieur borloo le ministre en
l'occurrence en fonction actuellement à
une volonté il a des déclarations moi je
l'entends et je le rencontre
régulièrement aussi pour lui dire écoute
et faut aller un peu plus vite parce que
c'est immédiat en fait en réalité c'est
un bon il est plein de bonne volonté
sauf que il ya un timing à respecter moi
je pense que l'urgence elle est ici et
maintenant elle n'est pas dans 10 ans
c'est ça la réalité il faut
impérativement répondre tout de suite il
faut qu'on accélère d'ailleurs il a dit
lui-même puisque nous on l'avait dit
avant mais il a dit lui-même la
situation des quartiers c'est une course
poursuite aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup fadela amara d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je voudrais
juste terminée sur un point il ya des
initiatives dans les quartiers qui sont
importantes
vendredi à 10 à 10 heures place de la
mairie à une marche organisée par la
famille de bouna et ziad une marche qui
dénonce seul à la fois les violences qui
rend hommage aussi à la mort de ses deux
jeunes enfants avec les associations au
delà des mots et une autre association
qui travaille avec eux je pense qu'il
faut mobiliser les gens ce sont des
initiatives comme celle ci qu'il faut
saluer merci beaucoup fadela amara
d'avoir répondu à nos questions